thanks again and sorry to push you into
the coffee break but we want to
momentum from the first panel as we now
go up one level of analysis we've
already talked a little bit about
international leverage western
engagement some of the developments that
might be going on in the region and so
we're looking now at regional
international and international trends
and responses and we have formally a
panel of three very distinguished
speakers and I'm not going to go over
their BIOS because you have them but I
might also just exercise some discretion
towards the end of panel ask selected
people who are able to join us here to
also weigh in on some international
developments too so our first panelist
will be a Navajo Imam ova who is a
broadcaster for the voice of America
Uzbek service and she's going to be
talking about who's Becca stands Foreign
Relations welcome thank you thank you so
much it's a pleasure and honor to be
here I usually get to cover these events
and yet to be up there asking questions
and it's nice to you know share my
insights sometimes too I usually try to
keep them to myself but one asks why not
I'm a proud to be away broadcaster but
obviously what I'm going to see here are
really my own views and none of the
voice of America I have a lot to say
Alex so please stop me any time and
hopefully we'll get to a lot of issues
in the Q&A part 2 what I would like to
do is really to explore some of the
factors that I believe drive
Uzbekistan's dealings with the world
thinks that we don't really discuss much
specifically with the United States and
them and Russia I have been watching use
BIC politics and foreign relations for
the past 18 years I was first introduced
to them to what you can call us back
foreign policy circle in 1995 as a as a
part-time producer and reporter and
editor for the use of X state radio that
time was a century ago when you look
back at what's happening in Tashkent now
there was a lot of foreign news coverage
then coming out of dash cams and there
was a huge emphasis on covering news
Vegas time
relations with the world it was almost
like a government agenda they really
wanted the people to know what who's
Vegas tan wanted from the world and what
kind of ties it was trying to develop
but it was very obvious to me even then
that there was no organizing principle
no vision um it almost seemed there was
no strategic vision for it was vegas
town what they wanted was this there was
this desperation to be recognized to be
treated as an equal partner you know to
be to be seen on the world stage as this
unique nation with great culture and
history and that those are the things
that we keep on hearing from music
officials even after 22 years you know
somehow they they have this agenda as
long as we push our grade history and
culture as one of our mean you know
belongings then we can we can get
somewhere and to me that mindset has not
really changed the same concern about
status to be status to be continues to
be the focus of loues Beck foreign
policy and the result is what we've been
discussing here every perceived slight
or criticism is taken very personally
it's treated as a as an urgent matter of
state and and a great deal of energy
spent in Tashjian to really silence the
critics and erase the criticism to to
blunt the the organizations or people
who are sort of targeting Uzbekistan
it's great mentality and culture and
history again so and what Vegas town
obviously fails to see is that you know
they need to change the policy if they
want to be taken differently instead of
vilifying who are you know those who are
criticizing to me this is a 22 year old
carrot characteristic which has the
qualities of an inferiority complex in
which the state is really unable to see
to look at itself critically because any
change in its behavior is obviously will
be
in his weakness and admission of guilt
sort of a very conflicted personality
that you know I see Las Vegas tannaz and
so based on that personality then you
can't understand how complex and
challenging it is to maintain a
relationship with this Vegas tan because
you know you never know what it is going
to do next is it going to go back into
the arms of Russia or is it going to
warm up to the unit United States it's
almost like a love of hair you know you
get fine you know where were the United
States for a while for as long as we're
comfortable with them but as soon as
they piss us off we will will move you
know to to to Russia Orion back and
forth you may say that other Central
Asian governments are like that too you
know you're dealing with a very hyper
sensitive system which is definitely
centered around one man you know who
sometimes seems very sophisticated and
confident but can also be very nervous
and narcissistic you have to constantly
temper and calibrate all of your
interactions with this you know
personality in order to avoid a crisis
or a fracture in the relationship and
based on my reporting from Washington
you know covering us Uzbek relations
that's what I see you know everything
that they do is to they have to
calibrate they have to be so careful
because they think that well as soon as
we you know we don't want to we don't
want to lose what we have with cream off
and and it's not to see that you know
green mouth is very confident in
Tashkent and seeing that while i'm
setting the agenda here there's a lot of
nervousness in Tashkent to and and
everything is very personal the this is
a government which is very insular and
its decision-making is very a big it
reports to nobody it definitely does not
report to its own people it does not
want to report to the international
community as much as we wanted to it
never feels any sense of responsibility
to explain its intentions its goals with
the world it doesn't matter whether
you're China Russia or the United States
with the European Union
Challenge is really the same the
Russians obviously a more sophisticated
than sort of accustomed in to this
mindset and so they know how to act
accordingly they know how to play with
with Islam Karimov but it is very
difficult for the Americans even after
22 years the relationship Washington
really doesn't know I can see how to
maneuver you know itself and you know
China and Russia if you look at them
they are investing in Uzbekistan Russia
is the closest partner China's trying to
catch up you know they do in business in
Tashjian despite the lack of
convertibility despite the lack of
transparency despite a lot of problems
that Western businesses may see well we
can't really do any business and Vegas
down Russians are making money one could
see that well Russia and China they
suffer from the sea maladies from
similar pathologies but you know they
want to do business they've they want to
make money so they're finding ways it
may be easy for us to look at the
current level of us who's back
relationship and say that well you know
things this is the beginning of a
longer-term upward trend a lot of
experts in Washington you know refer to
bath however nobody in the Obama
administration will honestly define the
relationship as excellent or even good I
mean off the record they say oh my god
you know it's very challenging on the
record they say improving those are the
two words and this definitely reflects
Washington sensitivities and awareness
of how difficult it is to deal with
career moves regime you know just
because you get to have two and a half
hours with aslam cream of once a year in
Tashkent does not mean that you get to
see apart I mean karima of likes to have
two and half meetings with let's see
with American officials where he talks
between two hours and 20 minutes and
then he lives you exactly 10 or less
than 10 minutes to thank him you know if
you see him and for so
I mean the the official meetings the way
sometimes we in the media way so
desperate to define the relationship
seeing that fine you know they meeting
obviously they warming up to each other
but behind the scenes there's a lot of
challenge and just because they're
talking to each other doesn't mean that
they're understanding each other I mean
there's one lat I mean there is no
mutual trust between two governments we
know that I mean despite what you hear
it dashcam and here in Washington we
move has very deep seeded ingredients
with Washington I mean you know that go
back as stars the early 1990s just you
know if we want to go back they were
unfulfilled promises by Bill Clinton you
know of great economic investment
treating with Vegas down like an equal
partner and of course the inflated
expectations about the strategic
partnership was George Bush it might
seem like a century ago for us but in
Greenland smile it's very personal this
is very recent history you know I'm
describing this from the perspective of
an authoritarian leader who's blind to
the fact of course that none of those
great expectations great things he had
hoped four would happen absent the lack
of transparency you know absent the
absent the liberalization of the economy
and of course those great expectations
were then dashed by what happened in
antigen by the color evolutions that
cream off till today beliefs were
instigated perhaps by the founders of
this conference and of course the lowest
point in the relationship you know was
driven lower when you saw the rational
restrictions this was incomprehensible
for Fatah Sheehan for curry modes like
how come I mean I'm a new partner you
know on the war on terror I am
prosecuting thousands of religious
extremists you know I'm in bed with you
and why are you doing this to me and
this was I mean we might choose what the
report about sometimes you know but when
you talk even today when you talk to us
big officials of course they all talk to
you off the record they like they're
shocked they refuse to I miss
and at times have gone that you know the
they're incapable to look at themselves
critically and say well perhaps we could
have taken a different step and and I
want to you know highlight something
here which is this is a yam personal and
very recent history for garima we might
think that it happened you know 10 years
ago or 15 but in his mind it's really
difficult for Tashkent deal with
Washington because people are changing
in Washington all the time so you know I
mean imagine President grima has been
there for over 22 years and how many US
officials he has seen over the past 22
years and they're constantly changing
and right when Tashjian thinks that is
you know it has hit it with somebody is
gone Donald Rumsfeld great friend and
Washington gone and then Condoleezza
Rice comes and they start hammering
Kareem off on human rights you know
imagine how happy Islam Karimov was to
see Hillary Clinton twice in Tashkent
she's gone now he can he feels like if
you not rely on anybody and that's
really you know that make that makes
them very frustrated the you know now we
have sort of a real-life station let's
see between the u.s. and whose biggest
and some of them but we cannot forget
that the restrictions some of the
restrictions really temporary to husavik
SAR fixated on rational restrictions we
might we might think that they are sort
of temporarily lifted this often but for
them they are still there and especially
the the part that you know limits the
security and defence cooperation and but
but at the same time they're not taking
any steps to improve the situation you
know so that washing you can live them
and this is a challenge for Washington
because no matter what they want to do
let's see the State Department the
Pentagon they have to go to Congress and
explain it then yet it okay so I hear us
officials constantly telling us Beck's
please you know do something to help us
so that we can help you and and there's
a lot of frustration that that's
happening I mean as we know as as we
just heard about you know different
issues especially when it comes to human
rights and democracy there's also this
constant talk in Washington about what
should the priorities be you know
following 2014 and obviously the top
priority is maintaining the logistical
access to Afghanistan I think that's
going to be a top priority for the next
two years they always mention economic
development human dimensions which
obviously you know include human rights
and democracy promotion educational
exchanges people-to-people contacts but
make no mistake I think that you know
these are really marginal objectives
when you when you compare to those
related to Afghanistan and one thing
that you know dash cam is very concerned
about is the departure of ICF forces
from Afghanistan but also the
implications of for both for both its
immediate security and its ability to
maintain a separate balanced
relationship with Russia and I think
that's something that cream off probably
really yeah it was worried about you
know we all know that Russia has been
using a very negative narrative about
the likely consequences of the ICF whose
role to build support for its own
presence and influence in Central Asia
Putin went to Vegas town as soon as he
came back as the president but also you
know despite Russian cooperation with
the United States and NATO by the way
they do a lot together logistically when
it comes to Afghanistan there is this
growing pressure on Tashkent than other
Central Asian capitals to to reject any
continued US presence in the region
Russian motivations are always very
complex there and they're always in
conflict with what they say publicly you
know that they support the international
effort I mean you know eighty-five
percent of what goes through in the end
goes through Russia and Russia allows
you know us aircrafts to overfly there
is a bilateral agreement that was signed
into n
10 and when you ask Russian officials
about this they very proud of it but at
the same time they don't want Central
Asians to be making their own decisions
you know when it comes to to the United
States we know that Russia is putting
heavy pressure on Kyrgyzstan not to
renew the minus agreement when it
expires in the summer of 2014 and one
thing that happened last year we saw
that the collective security treaty
organization decided to require all of
its members you know to secure this
unanimous consent of the csto partners
to permit any military base in the ax
territory and this was advanced by
Russia and this is definitely seen as
something aimed at the US and then was
vegas tan withdrew from the csto and
then of course Russian still claimed
that the country cannot get out of this
organization unless all other members
agreed to do so and also swagga Stan
rejected the proposal to host a csto
counterterrorism base but this doesn't
mean really that you know whose biggest
that may not go back into the
organization we have seen this I mean
they have a very you know they have a
love-hate relationship when it comes to
international organizations there was
this discussion about the entrance of
Central Asian countries into the World
Trade Center a World Trade Organization
last week in Washington and you know
Kyrgyz a very proud of the fact that
they have joined the organization
tajuk's haven't really taste it haven't
really gotten the taste of it but
they're eager to get in Cossacks are
working very hard to enter even through
commands as saying well we might really
want to join WTO and whose vixa cautious
which means that they don't know and
they don't want to say anything about it
there is nothing long-term when it comes
to us but foreign policy it's all about
maintaining the status quo sometimes it
almost seems to me that there is a
regime but the regime's mind is really
like what the slump em ups mind is you
know especially when it comes to foreign
policy and sometimes it's completely act
as if it's a miley system so you know we
can talk about what can happen next we
can make
own predictions but it's really about
one man and what you know how he sees
his what kind of a relationship he wants
to have with the United States but
definitely I mean for cream of American
relations with American matters because
he always uses them as a leverage
against Russia and you know back and
forth great I've all right thank you so
much really really rich and really
helpful I think just a couple things I
took from there this whole idea that
status drives foreign policy very key in
international relations especially in
American political science we always
talk about power and material interests
but in regimes like who's Becca stand
the status the public diplomacy this
Steve was saying earlier very important
critical in these episodes as a lens one
other thing I just took just to connect
to the previous panel this idea that
Russia controls eighty-five percent of
you n DN shipments never stopped us from
talking to rush about human rights if
anything it's the opposite right
relations are such a low again because
of mike nancy because of the human
rights issue comes up and yet ndn is
invoked all the time is a reason not to
talk to is becca Stan about human rights
so I think just just pointing out i
think that that that that contrasts are
your presentation okay next David Lewis
who I feel requires no introduction but
but I have to introduce him because he
is senior research fellow University of
Bradford just an incredibly prolific
scholar on contemporary issues in
Central Asia wrote fantastic book
temptations of tyranny and also the
author of a number a very helpful
analytical reports David thanks so much
Alex and thanks so much for invitation
lovely to be here and great see a whole
day devoted to Uzbekistan and really a
very timely and I think panel given
what's going on at the moment I think
there's one thing we can all agree about
what happened in the Middle East it's
that we didn't know enough before
going on internally in countries like
Libya and Syria and however far you want
to push the parallels the lack of
understanding of internal processes
seems to me to be key but I just want to
pick up really from we left off in a way
and take on some of the security aspects
that obviously so dominate this
relationship with the west and with the
United States in particular and i think
is very difficult to talk about security
policy and as becks down the way because
you enter this slightly odd world it
seems to me of sentiment of myth-making
slightly fantasy world sometimes that is
maybe part of Korea mom's worldview of
course so I just want to pick up what I
think of two discourses if you want to
use that word on security and as Becca
Stan and they're linked but they're
slightly different and the first one I
think is this classic discourse it
everybody knows about and just to give
you a quote I'll use a quote from former
ambassador inspected on John herbst who
i'm sure some people here will remember
from his time there during 2002 three
and he's got not to come out this week
on Radio Free Europe Ashley in which he
says flows northward from Afghanistan of
terrorists and narcotics will put a
greater risk a region already weakened
by corruption despotism and ethnic and
water tensions so another optimistic
view of the region but really I own the
folks on this idea of over sville this
constant metaphor of drivers of
instability moving north profitable and
from Afghanistan in this focus
particularly on
radicalism and narcotics it seems to me
this is a very useful sort of discourse
for the international community and for
present groom himself it's a shared
discourse in the first place we talked a
little bit about diplomatic negotiations
with the other government I think one of
the problems in those negotiations is is
what do you talk about come like once
you've you know got through all the
things you disagree about you need to
you need to end on some the point of
shared shared ideas and Afghanistan is a
great one to come to because in a sense
there is at least two shared interest in
stability south of the border it also i
think pleasing this idea of status as
pakistan sees itself as a key player on
the african issue it likes to push these
formats in which it would be significant
influence such as six plus one and so
forth and so I think it's a useful
shared discourse that provides a certain
amount of common ground between the two
sides of course share discourses also
have material outcomes like shared
funding shared military equipment
perhaps all sorts of implications that
we don't maybe think about when were in
that complicated meeting with the O's
back for a minister and but let's look
at this in reality to what extent is
this view of Uzbekistan security threats
corresponding to the reality that we can
see coming out in 2013 2014 now of
course what goes on the side after
council is hugely unpredictable but
let's pick out the two main points here
one is this alleged floor terrorists
that is supposed to be coming across the
border and the other is this flow of
narcotics now in terms of a flow of
terrorists as hell puts it we looked at
the most part potential of the Islamic
movement of Uzbekistan and other Taliban
linked groups that at the moment for the
most part are fighting on the F pack
border of them reappearing in the north
and challenging respects down from
across the border in other words
re-engaging the kind of thing they did
in 1999-2000 trying to cross the border
into Tajikistan Kyrgyzstan and challenge
was Becca Stan as a guerrilla insurgency
outfit with in Central Asia now it seems
to me this is at the moment at least in
a present configuration or reasonably
unlikely scenario the for the most part
the IMU seems to me to be quite deeply
embedded in this broader pan Taliban
movement it has a much much stronger
link to Pakistan and it did have five or
six years ago and its funding seems to
me to be predicated primarily on its
engagement against the government in
Afghanistan and against NATO forces so
it seems to me that that risk is
possible of course but slightly
exaggerated in terms of a real shift in
power in Afghanistan as well worth
bearing in mind that is Pakistan survive
really reasonably well when the Taliban
were occupying ninety-five percent of
Afghanistan's territory even after the
defeat of Dustin which you might have
thought was a key moment for four years
bags in 1998 there was still really the
prospect of a military confrontation
across the border I think was very
limited and then finally of course you
know this this idea of this terrorist
threat on his bike star has of course
been used instrumentally by the regime
constantly over the last 20 years as a
way of generating its own internal
oppressions and you know even on the
most if you like a charitable argument
in favor of these big government I think
you could calculate that you're much
more likely to have been killed by the
as bad government in the last one
years than by an international terrorist
group insiders biggest tragic but I
think true of course in that sense
although the IMU remains a potent force
within the region the actual threat to
this all controlling regime as I think
mr. Mara was talking about earlier seems
to me to be rather limited actually and
then finally of course on this point of
this alleged blur of terrorists coming
north if we're talking about a spillover
historically actually this bulova has
gone the other way the IMU was not
invented in afghanistan's it invented in
small towns of post-soviet was Beck
Fergana Valley and it emerged from that
very chaotic period of misgovernance in
the early 1990s it then spread out of
course from was becca Stan into
Tajikistan and down to where it's now
based in Afghanistan and the same you
could say about his booked a career
which again was a invention within
respect society itself helped of course
by invoice from London but nevertheless
we've seen as based on not so much the
victim of some of these security threat
but in a way as a fertile ground for
their production and reproduction so I'm
a little skeptical about how this this
might work in practice in
in terms of the post-2014 afghanistan
there's a lot of other issues we discuss
and others more knowledgeable in
afghanistan might chip in on the role
the of a community in that post-2014
several months or so for the thing i
just want to pick up on this block
office because it's important and
because it feels so much tomorrow I'm
bad international policy in the region
you know again the idea it seems to be
that as soon as I surf forces leave
suddenly open production will skyrocket
and the way huge increased flow of
opiates across the Afghan as back and
Afghan tajuk borders in reality we all
know the situation which is the
production and export has gone on
largely unscathed by any Western
counter-narcotics programs and for the
most part these northern trafficking
routes through Central Asia I'm not
controlled by organized crime in
opposition to the state but are
controlled by figures who are very
closely related to the US back and other
states in the region and I don't see any
change in terms of that systemic reality
which is that narcotics flows through
the region will continue to be
controlled for the most part by senior
security officials or organized crime
groups under the control of regimes in
the region the partial exception to that
is Kyrgyzstan but there you have very
complicated and often slightly chaotic
situation of course and as Becca Stan
and all controlling state also controls
organized crime flows as well so of
course in terms of a shifting in power
inside Afghanistan you might well of
course they're shipped in trafficking
networks but to my mind the reality on
the other side of the border will remain
in control and prevent the kind of
violent upsurge of violence that you
might expect with a shift in trafficking
patterns so why do we keep on with this
this handy discourse of overflows and /
spills and other strange metaphors
coming from the south what I say it's
very useful in terms of some kind of
shared conversation a shared narrative
and of course it has material benefits
in terms of keeping the financial flows
going and the military flow is going in
the post-2014 period we're not going to
get too much interest from the West in
the region unless there is the security
hook that you can keep people hooked on
I just want to I don't know how I'm
doing evidence yeah five minutes just
want of flick to what seems to me to be
the real discourse of security if you
like within within the I never quite
know what they call it was very
government we're really talking about
inside President Correa Rob's mind
perhaps which is a metaphor freedom and
there I think we see a rather different
set of challenges that come to the fore
repeatedly and some of the men picked up
already and I will just give a quick
quote from prison curry not because we
haven't had one yet should always have
one in his kind of cages and this is him
not talking to you in touch with windy
but talking to military officers back in
January in other words a domestic
occasion another highlight although
dimensions Afghanistan the highlight
years serious challenges and threats are
emerging due to the intensification of
activities by armed gangs and subversive
and terrorist groups in border areas as
well as because of social and economic
problems political and inter-ethnic
conflicts that could lead to destabilize
table ization of the military political
situation
on our borders so in other words the
focus here is on what I think it cause
of internal external enemies these does
affect communities outside the country
which he sees as hotbeds of potential
opposition to the regime partly because
of course he hasn't been able to control
them in the way that he has the internal
population and these are respect
communities particularly in ocean view i
abide in you Stan where of course there
is a very strong presence of groups like
his boat a clear southern Kazakhstan
whereas certainly at various points that
have been between evidence averse exiles
from Uzbekistan I'm trying to organize
including some might call near Salafi
groups or Islamist groups and of course
much further afield we've already talked
about this huge population of migrant
workers in in Russia and that also
includes of course some political
activists and religious activists and so
on and so forth and so if you look at
security practices of these big state
what they actually do in practice we've
already touched on this Steve mentioned
it earlier on this very active
counterintelligence operations in Russia
going into Russian places of detention
to interrogate those backs on Russian
territory for example we've heard about
allegations of killings in Sweden or
assassination attempts in Sweden against
with hondas are of we were poor
statically in the past of journalists in
Kyrgyzstan sigh PSA above and so I
suggest that actually if you look at
what the SNB is focusing on on an
everyday basis a lot of it is focused on
these communities along as back borders
where it sees potential threats coming
in the future I think that's both for
real reasons of a sense that if somebody
wants to try and stir up trouble inside
as bagestan this is a place to start but
I think it also has really useful
outcomes in domestic politics the last
thing you want if you're an
authoritarian government such as as
becca stan is to focus on internal
discontented source of security the best
thing is these kind of internal external
enemies where it's all the fault of
somebody else outside the country Russia
stage soups or local society perhaps but
anyway from kind of external source of
destabilization linked to internal
groups that you can then repress in your
internal repressive measures and so I
think this this very strong
concentration on these aspect
communities Outsiders bekstaarr has been
a constant light motif of criminals
policy and has led to a whole series of
policies that have been very
counterproductive in terms of regional
security these are the closed borders of
course these are very securitized
relationship to the enclaves zin
southern Kyrgyzstan that we've just seen
in the last month throwing up these very
difficult relationships between the
Kyrgyz and aspects this is part of the
reason I think for this constant
crackdown on cross-border trade and
cross-border investment sure there's a
kind of self-interest in terms of self
enrichment but there's also this
obsession with cross border security
that has
and stuff as well I suggest it's also a
potential explanation for part of this
new increased concern about Russian
migrants abroad is the security
implications of these groups outside the
country not only listening to ray for
euro of course but in Russia in relation
to a very strong continued I think real
concern about the security policy of
Russia in the region now so just finally
I think we need to rethink some of our
understandings of security in the region
particularly at this idea that was
biggest on somehow gets a free pass
because it's on the border with
Afghanistan and therefore face is this
constant flow of terrorists in my
father's coming northwards actually we
need to focus on as Pakistan not so much
as a regional security provider but as a
source of instability in the region that
needs to redress some of its domestic
politics and foreign policy to try and
improve overall regional stability
including the Dennis create David thanks
so much for that presentation that
perspective and especially bringing this
regional dimension and the sort of
inside out to light that's just
something you just don't read about in
the popular media and sort of coverage
of these issues last but never means
lentil etre vice president of operations
of the crisis group in Brussels has
always has his finger on the pulse of EU
and NATO relations of Central Asia a
board member of the central Eurasia
project I lack can you fill us in on the
latest thinking in Brussels about whose
Becca stand and the challenges of
dealing with is Becca Stan or otherwise
suitably entertain us yeah but i would
start if you allow me with where david
has finished I think one of the greatest
danger widows Pakistan facing the future
is that the lack of knowledge of what is
going on within the country and you're
quite right to underline the dimu is not
in Afghanistan invention that an Uzbek
invention and because all of thousand
are out icg has never managed to get the
mission to open enough is in touch can't
even though we are several times for an
official permission and the answer was
funny that we got from the US bank
embassies that you are cold the craziest
group we have no crisis you know we are
in the capital d you a KD using crisis
no it was not when we are to open their
Human Rights Watch director for us Beca
stone is here and not in Tashkent right
amnesty is out the OSCE offices now new
cadets that you underline this morning
and I don't trust our diplomats from all
of our Western well minded countries to
do a wonderful job in going out into the
Fergana Valley having cloth in you know
in some mahala's where you have young
people being extruded you know turning
more and more to Islam and radical Islam
as an answer to the angers not the
angers not so much the angers buddy on
quests you know the the pro-q patients
they have for their life in which they
see no future now about the relationship
between NATO and his Becca stone and the
UN is becca's and thank you for giving
to me this wonderful topic I will make
the fezzes this morning that what is
extremely amazing to me and formidable
after everything we heard about Islam
Karimov this morning is that almost
eight years after Andy John in my view
Karimov has succeeded in reshaping the
relationship with NATO and we do you
according entirely to his interest and
do his narrative and I find out I find
it I'm almost Amira tvoem he's been
quite good of doing that so we'll start
with EU with the you angle and okay to
make but have to be careful because we
have Jackie here who's who knows these
things much better than me but okay to
simplify a little bit Jackie when you
say EU approach towards Uzbekistan you
have to think mainly French British and
German approach but they should start
with Germany
British and French approach and you have
the few member states which are
extremely active on all the questions
that we are preoccupied about in this
room this morning that is you know
opening a little bit disis iety opening
up a little bit space for society in dec
dictatorship one of them is Lithuania
the other one is Sweden and the third
one is Poland and so in the European
councils or the so-called I have to be
careful in my pronunciation here the
so-called faq which means Foreign Affair
Council don't take me wrong place this
is 12 27 ministers of Foreign Affairs
meet in Brussels this is called a fact
right so in the FAQ and ass Pakistani
always have D to these two poles
basically those who are promoting crayon
politic right it's a word that has now
this is sounding very well in French to
lately particularly when we speak about
this becca Stan and the other the other
pole which is my boots and that the
leadership of Sweden but sometimes also
we Lithuania and Poland taking the lead
but okay d you has tried its best in the
in a way during the German chairmanship
of the European Union 2007 they set up
this there's a strategy for Central Asia
they came up with a whole part of it and
human rights and democratization with
the results we've seen I would say that
the impact of the strategy and the place
like Uzbekistan has been really close to
nil but saying that I wouldn't like to
dismiss the efforts they were some
efforts not easy to deal with regime
like Islam Karimov on the human rights
issue I don't want to underline that too
much we heard several times this morning
but the funny thing and this is a place
I would say where the Americans and the
Europeans are more or less the same
approach and the key word to describe
the the reactions of our diplomats
Western diplomats let them be EU let
them be us see let them be
American or European members day is the
same expression that I heard from an
American ambassador the first year I put
my feet in tashkent was in 1995 and the
expression is there is a window of
opportunity so we are still hearing that
now there are some movements and
positive mood and then if you try to ask
them can you quote one then you have
nothing so um the would be you there has
been the sanction issue after Andy John
and it has been in my views a huge
fiasco the EU has proved widows Pakistan
that it is incapable of holding up on
sanctions on the few tough issues when
there is no consensus between the 27
member states so the sanctions have not
work and i would say that Karimov came
out reinforce in front of him in his own
constituency but also on the
international stage and in front of his
neighbors for Selena's abaya because you
know the day the the competition for
status are like I like the way you
describe the state is between the two
remains pretty high well I think today I
would say do you has lost any strategic
vision of what it wants to achieve with
Tashkent it is still putting in some
monies in things that I find completely
useless in the best of cases but
perverse in the worst of cases like for
instance these ten millions for
judiciary reforms in the countries we
heard in-depth today what the judiciary
is not at all in the mood of being
reformed the judiciary's an instrument
of the dictatorship to bring all its
opponents and all those who would make
some money not only the political
opponents but those who make some money
and refuse to hand it over to guna
recurring ova so I think this
initiatives are in my view is very
negative and I've been speaking about
that often in Brussels because they give
a very cheap way for the use by
government to say to the world listen we
are reforming and the good the best
proof of it is that you use putting
money in our reforms now let's move to
NATO well to NATO with nater I think I
think there are a few figures that have
not been put on the table I found it in
an article from you know by Heidi
Reisinger from the NATO defense college
before I store the analysis just a few
figure so she says that to move out of
Afghanistan NATO will have to remove
125,000 containers up to 80,000 vehicles
the british defence extreme said that
Britain alone expects to get around one
sorry eleven thousand containers and
three thousand armed vehicles back from
Afghanistan Germany will have to bring
back six thousand containers and more
than 500 vehicles the cost of one flight
one-way flight of an Antonov 124 cargo
plane bringing 12 containers from
Germany to Afghanistan can be up to 350
thousand euros the cost per container
for cow go through the ndn is
approximately seventeen thousand five
hundred dollars compared to
approximately seven thousand two hundred
dollars for cargo through Pakistan
ground roots okay and I seen another
figure that's the last month it's quite
telling a thing to be out of Afghanistan
by 2015 it would require from NATO to
have a container leaving Afghanistan
every seven minutes from basically the
date when his article came out which I
can't find it it was June 2012 so I'm
just putting these figures in front of
you because I think what has made Karim
of win all his battles up to now on the
international stage seen
is his diplomatic style and you describe
that very well I hear it from all our
officials who have had a meeting with
him he speaks for about one hour and 30
of all the the enemies here's around and
then the other ones if he's a bit more
yeah he spent some more time with
foreign officials exactly because they
have a shared narrative that we've just
heard and then then well i think i think
his toughness has been his best weapon
when you go into a meeting your chaff
and you know that anyway people in front
of you don't have many retaliation if
you're tough you're in a very good
position to negotiate and the second
term his second tool is I'm sorry I
forgot he wrote it down but the
healthier victim a no is well what you
mentioned also several times in
predictability if there is someone the
Russians have learned from Karimov is
his in predictability well the Americans
also won big I don't remember many
places in the world after world war two
where the Americans have been notified
to close down military bases over six
months so this is one of the only places
i think it's good for America that
sometimes they have to face problems
like this it's good for the sense of
power but I'm not sure it's sorry sorry
I shouldn't say that here but I'm not
sure it's good for us Beca Stan so if
you keep in perspective the figures i
I've just mentioned the position where
he is my only prediction is that
compared to other countries in Central
Asia where there is slightly more
transparency about both the money our
countries are ready to pay to get our
troops out and the kind of weapon raised
they will leave on the ground I have
been unable to find one single reliable
figure about this becca Stan if you have
I'd be happy to hear that and I'm unable
to find today any reliable sources about
the kind of military weapons that our
countries are ready to live in
Uzbekistan but what if our current
analysis is more
is true can be predictable is that the
tougher the removal of our troops out of
Afghanistan will be the higher the
stakes will be in tashkent and the more
Kerimov will be asking so this is more
or less where I am I think kerimov in in
this particular moment is in a very
strong position he has got a strong
political leverage both with EU and with
NATO his visit to Brussels in 2011 was a
point in this process basically it was
received by Secretary General Rasmussen
and afterwards by borough so i'm not
sure barossa understood that he should
you know why he had to meet this guy
because he had a demonstration in front
of the bell mo palace but during the
meeting with with Rasmussen there was an
interesting moment also because karima
was quite happy to get this meeting and
the meeting was going pretty well til at
a certain point someone who told me the
story put a small paper under the nose
of mr. Rasmussen and he told me I
thought I love I lost my job that day
saying well as the meeting is going well
maybe you should talk to him about the
famous reverse course you know pres
monson's raised this issue and the
attitude of Karimov change and he did
with mr. Rasmussen what he did with
several of the officials who have met
with him he forgot where he was became
red in his face of anger banked with his
fist on the table and said if you want
to talk about the reverse course we will
stop talking about anything else that
we're talking about right now so that's
the way Karim of deals with Westerners
and so my conclusion is rather sad in
this kind of situation till all the NATO
troops are out of Afghanistan I'm not
quite sure about the leverage we have
and I'm sorry to be contradicted a
little bit the recommendations of the
Human Rights Watch I think you're right
to firm your
these recommendations but i think the
the narrative is now on carom off side
and basically this is the result of
western countries allowing themselves to
be hostage of a dictatorship like this i
don't think any of our countries in the
position is in the position to put any
caveat under discussion and the money's
there karim of wants maybe more on the
weaponry but even they are not quite
sure sory for this rather pessimistic
conclusion i am pretty confident down if
I want to conclude on something more
positive that after this that is maybe
in 2016 2017 maybe even though yes Gary
Muffy is very disturbed by our
democratic system where people don't
stay in power for 20 years democracy
Seth sometimes the short memories that
in some cases they can have a long
memory and I I would not conclude by
saying that our countries will not
remember how they will have been treated
there thank you Allah I thanks so much
and just to link this back to what David
was talking about in that Times of
London piece on military left behind
equipment UK minister of defense was
quoted as saying ordinarily we do not
give military equipment to countries
where might be used for domestic
repression but in this case that lose
Beck's have a legitimate concern about
counter-narcotics and spillover right i
mean just are justifying one with the
other and i found that really telling
and and just you know one other
observation it strikes me not only is
that lose by government has a reputation
in washington and certainly brussels of
being just the toughest negotiators a
lot of these officials have ever met I
mean just stylistically even they can't
talk about the subsonic oh she Asians
just throw their hands up in the air now
take a lance point about the urgency of
what needs to be done logistically right
and
then feed that into sort of our notions
of bargaining leverage and it seems to
me one of the tales that's going to be
told about the ndn and this applies to
reverse transit as well it was meant to
increase Western options it was meant to
increase Western bargaining power
because if the Pakistani shut it down
we'd go through the northern route if
northern route a shutdown we go through
poti or the Taji group instead it seems
to have had the opposite concerned by
actually spreading out political
vulnerabilities and compromises so now
we compromise with the Pakistanis and
with the effects and all the way across
why because a multiple an alternate
route is only credible if you're willing
to use it if you're willing to stop
stuff going through one route and ship
it in the other and that's one thing I
just haven't seen either on endianness
or reverse transit negotiators do to
actually get the leverage that they
organizationally set this thing up to
deal with anyway that's my rant I do
want to just ask we have a couple
members in the audience first Alison
Gill howson are you here Alison and also
Matthew from the cotton campaign the
pressure came back you guys like to
maybe just offer some thoughts at the
mic about since we're doing the
international side of things just where
you see the cotton campaign going what
have been some of its challenges and
successes maybe connect to some of the
points that have been made there I think
this would be a really good time to get
your perspectives on these issues sure
thank you so not exactly picking up on
the comments here perhaps a little bit
more on some of the comments earlier
today and that is this notion of the
link between the economy and human
rights and I thought it was appropriate
that Scott opened up the session talking
about the limits of naming and shaming
and you know as i coordinate the cotton
campaign part of what we do is certainly
to name and shame but there are
significant limits to that
when looking at something like the
state-sponsored forced labor of children
and adults and there's by cotton sector
it is not only an abuse of rice there
are financial factors involved and
therefore for trying to change that we
need to look at the incentives around
that system and so a lot of what we do
is the cotton campaign is to look for
leverage and earlier today some of the
comments expose some rather significant
lovers that we can use to drive change
when I mean change I'm talking about no
forced labor the cotton sector is not
only a way for the elites to earn money
and when I say elites that's throughout
the government that's the central level
but also at the regional and district
levels in the last 20 years has only
been more hands into the pot of cotton
income not fewer so that as complicated
matters but it's also a control
sociological control and when when we
look at interviews our colleagues who
monitor the cotton harvest every year
they conduct hundreds of interviews
every year and actually just just this
week I've been reading a lot of those
and the way people describe coercion in
order to go pick cotton is that they
just know the consequences of refusing
it is almost a that the state has
achieved the introduction of our
cultural norm that you grew up in this
society and you know that your
livelihood depends on compliance with
authority and authority in the sense
that they are taking you out of your
school taking you out of your job taking
you away from your business or taking
resources away from your business and
we've seen a really strong push on the
private sector the last few years to
contribute to the cotton harvest so all
of these people from children from
students from adults from
businesses they are funding the
government's cotton sector I mean that's
really what we're talking about those
funds as was pointed out earlier today
there's no transparency around them very
clear that they're not being reinvested
into the country there's a lot of people
that are benefitting off of that so how
do you reduce the incentives for that
status quo to remain and one of the
points that Sanjar brought up today was
the link between the commercial sector
which faces a really unpredictable and
high-risk investment environment and
human rights and I would suggest that
perhaps the link is rule of law when it
comes down to it the cotton campaign is
advocating for meeting established
commitments we're advocating for the
government to meet its national laws on
forced labor which means stopping the
practice of using coercion to have
people provide free labor in the cotton
sector we're asking the EU in the u.s.
to look at yes there is a very limited
space for diplomatic intervention but
there are lots of other avenues where
they can exert their authority if
they're not willing to have bilateral
discussions on human rights well how
about using their voice and vote at the
international financial institutions or
how about exerting more pressure on
other UN agencies like the ILO to
actually go in and connect monitoring
but the third set of actors that I think
we haven't had a chance to explore here
is multinational companies they are very
well established and there's been this
last 10 years a real push to identify
what are the duties of multinational
enterprises when they're operating
anywhere but specifically when they're
operating in areas of high risk of human
rights violations and I think we can all
agree that respect estemos a
high-risk environment of human rights
violations so we're looking at companies
that are specifically buying cotton and
therefore they are profiting off of this
forest labor system but also many
companies that are operating in News
Pakistan and you know on face value have
nothing to do with cotton and yet their
continued operation is dependent on
complicity with this system complicity
by allowing their employees to go pick
cotton for free to pay them their salary
to pick cotton for the government or to
contribute resources small medium
enterprises this year we're forced to
contribute into a government bank
account in order to cover the cost of
people going to pick cotton no one's
being paid for that so it's both a duty
of multinational enterprises to say look
we can't be complicit in forced labor we
have our own codes of conduct we have
international standards there are
investors that will pull money if they
can identify the links between
multinational enterprises and forced
labor so how do we as an international
community engage multinationals to say
let's look at what you can do to use
your influence with respect government
which craves FDI I mean it's not a real
attractive place for entrepreneurs so
investing there is a risk can we use
that leverage a little bit better for
those businesses to encourage reforms
talking about caveats condition
continued an increased investment on
significant reforms great and so I just
leave it there to say you know it's
really for us about identifying points
of leverage to drive some change let me
just ask you some very brief reaction
appoint Steve made this morning about
the demographics of the cotton-picking
changing last year has been documented
from less smaller children more older
children do you see that as a strategic
response to the campaign have you been
able to connect the dots
um well as with most things in this
context i don't think the dots are
directly linked but yes there is a sense
that the government wants to expand the
cotton sector right they've been
attracting investors in cotton
Processing's we're talking about turning
continent a yarn those types of
facilities over the last seven years in
particular and as was brought up this
morning there have been some
difficulties in selling their cotton
because it is a risk for any
multinational company to be using news
by cotton that links them to a major
human rights violation so you know the
Uzbek government is certainly aware of
those pressures and yes I think there is
in some ways they responded by saying
okay nobody likes child labor so let's
let's show that there's no child labor
unfortunately the system is a bit out of
their hands I mean we still saw school
children with schools closed taken out
into the fields by government
authorities so there's there's limits to
their ability to handle this because
they're not being put in a position to
look at the root causes which is really
this issue of the agricultural sector
that was raised this morning great thank
you thanks much Alison do you have some
thoughts you can add or like to share on
this
I'm really interested in some of the
information that Alice share and others
have have brought up today about the new
technologies and ways that information
can be shared and spread in news becca
son and i hope we'll be able to get at
that maybe later this afternoon and
where where is there potential there to
connect some of the nascent networks
outside the country perhaps with what is
going on inside the country so if it's
very clear historically that major
pressure points have occurred around
economic issues so-called economic
reforms thinking of their forms that
were passed recently I'm also thinking
of reforms that were passed in 2004 that
sparked riots that we had never really
seen cars burning police officers being
threatened sort of as a precursor
perhaps to what happened in auntie Jean
but in direct response to a series of
economic changes so how how that those
networks and systems outside the country
perhaps can start to link to what is
happening inside the country now that
there is possibly the potential for
greater information to be shared or
possibly the potential for I don't want
to be too optimistic here but an
emerging transparency around abuses as
Matthew said it's very clear that it's
almost in the DNA of many moods effects
in the country that compliance with the
regime is essential but as as new
technologies emerge as perhaps there is
a greater discussion it will be quite
interesting to see if if the some
linkages can create a little bit of I
don't want to say pressure because
there's always pressure but a kind of
pressure that can perhaps lead to more
planning more policy great thanks so
much okay so we have the room until one
I am NOT going to give 15 minutes worth
of conclusion
very that well I'd say some thank yous
at the end so let's let's open this up
and you know again please step up the
microphone and just tell us who you are
so our panels know who they're
addressing into the question hi mask
enough for them the issue of leverage
now what are those multinational
corporations what are the names of those
corporations do they have shareholders
that they have shareholder meetings the
where people can attend so I mean has
anyone worked that out sure so exposing
companies that are operating in
Uzbekistan it depends on how link how
close they link that I used by
government for example our campaign has
currently been pushing daewoo
international which is a Korean based
company it's the elephant in the room in
terms of the cotton processing sector in
Uzbekistan and they also are a major
participant in global apparel supply
chains so there are various points of
entry but that being said there with
David's you know they're very complicit
in the system there are other companies
though that we can engage in a different
manner in a bit more of a more
engagement and less pressure perhaps but
firm nonetheless and I would suggest
that companies like like General Motors
they have a partnership with the Uzbek
government General Motors uzbekistan's
employees have been forced to pick out
in the last couple years and that's
problematic that also puts the General
Motors headquarters in a position of
needing to respond right and you know
there are instruments like the
organization for economic cooperation
and development guidelines from
multinationals and their complaint
process which allow us to engage those
companies shareholder actions are
certainly an option a lot of the
companies we're looking at don't have
significant investment at least in the
West but there are also sustainable
investment funds in
in South Korea and Asia that are
increasingly engaged in this and that's
as part of what we do is a campaign is
to identify partners that can take those
types of actions great thank you okay
other questions please yes Scott maybe
just a thought I mean one theme of the
of the presentations and this panel has
been the personal level the really
unusual level to which policy formation
and interaction with foreign States it
really is a function of the individual
personality of Islam premier my friend I
think in the earlier panel this morning
his daughter gulnara cream of also came
up as you know I powerful individual
personality who influences thing and it
just seems to me that I'm 11 tactical
approach to dealing with this is then to
approach the notion of sanctions and
countermeasures in an equally
personalized fashion not focusing on
criticism of Uzbekistan or the Uzbek
state not giving them the benefit of
associating themselves with the state
but focusing on the individuals and in
the period since the Arab Spring there
is something of a gradual shift
policy-wise amongst Western nations
amongst finance internations in this
regard so we have for instance the
executive policy statement that was
issued by president bush about visas
where he said you know it was a matter
of practice if we know someone's a
klepto crap that if someone uses a
position of official power to profit
themselves we don't issue visas to such
people we don't let them come in and
then the sector than the Attorney
General issued a policy state month
building off of that saying yeah and we
also view them as politically exposed
person
then we may very well require financial
institutions to give us special reports
about them and we may track their
dealings commercially and with financial
institutions and you know it just seems
to me that Uzbekistan may be very very
ripe for development in this regard
that's very interesting I mean the to me
it's all about the mentality I mean of
course you know we use vicks it's
sometimes I feel like it's in our blood
that we don't want to be criticized or
you know we kind of we take such pride
that well if you talk to a lot of people
in Uzbekistan they will try to still
convince you that well you know we are
one big family and then Islam Karimov is
our Father now would you be criticizing
your father you know in his face those
kind of arguments are unfortunately they
still sell I mean you can still convince
people that that's the right way of
doing things and I think it was big
political mentality whatever it is they
you know it still cannot accept the fact
that somebody from outside can come and
question your doings you know this is
everything again as I was saying earlier
it's all very personal and I think what
Tosh can't uses in a very sophisticated
way is also they rely they invest on the
fact that there's a huge lack of
political well in the in the capital's
you know for example in Washington or in
Brussels or in London even in Moscow and
Beijing how much of a political will is
there to say no to Tashkent if they
ultimately see now but can i push you on
that because you're Asian that ran a
story this week about this whole scandal
at the Atlantic Council and ties are
Chuck Hagel was there between Kazakhstan
and Chevron possible conflict of
interests that emerged in their kind of
fluffy reports and the strategic
partnership how much of an issue is this
in DC and is there a comparable kind of
uzbek lobby but whose by constituency in
Washington policy analysis and
institutes that access
just enough a believer the other way
that in these kinds of razor thin
decisions sort of allows the Uzbek
government have the benefit of the doubt
um and has it been changing a me start
when we're thinking he's because karima
I understand used to make fun of
Nazareth for blowing all this money on
Western lobby he said oh you're
ridiculous all right for doing this time
I mean I remember one briefing when you
know there were people called Richard
voucher dealing with Central Asia Ivan
Fagan bomb if you guys remember and in
2008 I think there was a briefing at the
Foreign Press Center and I asked a
question from Richard bowsher about nah
survives recent statement about what
couldn't happen in Central Asian terms
of regional integration very quickly I
get a response from music embassy and
they are outraged that I was crediting
nas abaya for throwing the side the
original integration because they
strongly believe that it originally came
from President cream off so you know if
we were discussing this we had to go
back and in history and see that while
this was originally career moves idea
and now another wife is growing the ball
again and that's how it yes but you know
there are people in Washington who have
been consistently supportive of the
regimes in Central Asia I mean we know
of many experts I mean these are people
who usually get invited to conferences
in touch can they get their trips to
bahara and summer come you know bring
back their beautiful exotic rugs and
pictures I mean I and and you know
embassies are constantly sort of
convincing your recruiting these people
to go and service election monitors even
if their backgrounds don't really I mean
they don't qualify to be doing that job
but there are people willing to go and
do the job for them but I mean in
Congress I can't I mean there may be two
or three people who really know and seem
to care about what's happening in
Pakistan or you know in other parts of
Central Asia I mean there is obviously
more interest in Kazakhstan because
there is a huge investment there but
when it comes to like you know when I go
cover hearings and briefings what what
is discussed is really like very likely
just touch upon the surface little
you know their superficial kind of
approach so even though I mean Tosh
can't always you know tries to have
friends in Washington and these are
people who get up in the in conferences
and talk or support sort of defend the
policies of Islam Karimov but in general
I mean they know that they cannot rely
on anybody and there's that there's that
peer to thank you very interesting damn
thanks to everybody so I tend to agree i
think with Ilan's rather pessimistic
analysis of our leverage at least until
the end of 2014 are being the west
however we choose to define that so
maybe we could kind of turn the
considerable analytical firepower of
this panel towards the for the post-2014
you know if the narrative is right now a
lot about instability and also the
demands of the kind of exit route from
Afghanistan what do we do with the
post-2014 period how do we encourage a
more values based foreign policy on the
part of the EU on the part of the US and
so on that's for anybody that wants to
tackle that thorny issue yeah great
thank you should we start letter and how
long you want to well I think any way
that we should already today insist from
our governments for some transparency I
was saying that there is no transparency
now on that one I think we can get at
least that pointing out to our
politicians the risk they are running
because that will be exposed one day I
think that's the filter for civil
society for simple citizens and voters
that's the first thing we can demand
then of course there was a very strong
argument that came out in the first
panel this morning it's the argument of
the the collapse of the US bank economy
if the analysis that we heard this
morning turns true in the coming months
if we see the regime
down on remittances I think if they do
that even though I agree with you that
they're those bags think that no Nash
Papa times idiot I think the love to the
father will disappear order what remains
of that possible love that will be
explosive and someone said this morning
i think it was caught who said this is
suicidal so there there might be I
believe I went sorry it was about safe
window of opportunity for for advocacy
on the fact that that NATO countries
negotiating the moved the reverse
transit have more level regional might
have an opening for more average now for
2014 what was just mentioned on these
personal and targeted sanctions it is
amazing when you think of the lifestyle
it that gulnara has that except for the
fashion week in New York basically very
few things as well the fashion week and
the the purchase of her house in in
Geneva and for those who don't know the
story that was very too beautiful to be
missed you know she bought a house that
was on the public register for sale of
the Geneva state and and in the register
the house cost 30 million swiss francs
and she bought it openly for 43 million
so you know all of us were suddenly
shouting in Geneva come on what is the
procure of the Republic doing here right
but except for these two cases when you
see how she lives around her lifestyle
in Barcelona and all that there has not
been targeting at all and of course what
what Alex the comparison you made with
Russia Magnitsky Act and the fact that
not only they never touch the the idea
of preventing NATO to overfly Russia but
even our good friend mr. rigazzi in whom
we've heard for several years bashing at
NATO in his position as Russian
ambassador
NATO in Brussels when I saw him on TV
one evening in julio navas the city of
lenin convincing the Communists of of
Liana's who were demonstrating against
the fact that the airport of julio navas
would be given over for net to nato that
this was necessary and it actually nato
was defending Russians interest in
Afghanistan I could not believe my ears
I think that the big difference is that
with the with Russia there is a some
more ability to separate the issues
because it's a big state a great power
great ministry of foreign affairs and in
spite of the the autocratic tendencies
of Putin the the there is not yet I
would sign Russia this kind of personal
issues that you described so perfectly
around Putin's personality as you have
in intosh candles karima so 4 2014 I
would say this D stacking both of
corporations that are leading poor
business there and the assets of the of
the regime abroad the asset's of the
regime is mainly in Western banks for
the moment they could move it to the ma
rights but it is still here David yes
yeah just briefly I think it is I also
I'm afraid sit in that pessimistic camp
and I did spend quite a few years with
international crisis group trying to
think of recommendations for the those
of a government well I had to leave in
the antics of course is very difficult I
mean it is very hard to find these
points of leverage and i agree i don't
think we do have a significantly version
moment which i think in post-2014 can
lead to some potentially bad options one
of those options is simply to walk away
and
you know the result of all these very
difficult negotiations will be a certain
amount of Central Asia fatigue among
diplomats and Brussels wantam and the
temptation to simply say well you know
we got our stuff out and that's it will
be quite high i think the seconds of a
bad option seems to me that somehow as
the conflict evolves in Afghanistan as
Beck's town will take on a new role as
sort of a new sort of forward base or
somehow a backup base of what's going on
in aspects done particularly if you see
a genuine Civil War opening up again a
very bad option i think for and going
down the road somewhere in the middle of
those there's something slightly more
optimistic i do think this
personalization of assets and the
economy is very important we've seen a
lot of reporting recently at the
TeliaSonera case and in sweden and
that's been I think quite a powerful
narrative that has potential
consequences and that's the important
thing I think so I didn't you know I
think if groups who do that kind of
reporting an investigation can do more
of that I think that'll be very very
potentially influential in the future
but finding real leverage points that
have short outcomes I think is very
difficult typically make sure you know I
mean you they came to me boils down to
how much political will do you have to
really be dealing with this guy you know
I mean I think unfortunately a lot of
folks in Washington have already given
up I maybe they think that it's useless
to really you know pressure this guy
he's not going to change and that you
know there is this defeatist position
like you know well how much do we really
want to push is it really worth it I
mean sometimes say I mean as a
journalist of course I'm not allowed in
those meetings but I want to be there
and I want to really watch how they
negotiate you know how they make those
deals I mean remember the time let's say
45 years ago when the u.s. big position
was so strongly opposing any programs
that were funded by the US you know no
we don't need any USB thing geo's we
don't need any exchange programs
you know people will go to China they'll
go to Russia they'll go to Japan to
study we don't need American schools
educating them meanwhile meanwhile a lot
of Ministers children were going to
school here in the United States and to
me that was sort of outrages I'm sitting
there I'm like are Americans raising
this I mean you had lazybone atif as the
foreign minister his daughter was in the
United States as a flex participant
which flags by the way is now abandoned
whose Vegas tan and this was the guy who
was seeing we don't need our teenagers
going to America and getting you know
brainwash then coming back and trying to
overthrow the regime his daughter was in
the United States his son was going to
school in Texas and you know so
sometimes I feel like how much do the US
officials want to really like say to
them yeah or maybe need to but they
really don't talk about that um without
ganna Stan of course the US but
government you know tries to sound very
concerned about what's happening in the
neighboring country and that they want
to be involved in the future of the
neighboring country but in reality there
is not there is no reporting of
Afghanistan you know Pakistan I mean
there is not there is no not much
reporting about anything inside the
country but the state media do not
report about what's happening in the
neighboring country the Foreign
Relations foreign issues are only
mentioned if karima auth is holding a
meeting or there's you know somebody
visiting in Tashkent but commerce
between Afghanistan I'm a US has been
working very hard to convince us vex to
do more business with Afghanistan
there's been there was I just learned
something there was zero export from
Afghanistan tues Vegas fan last year and
the trade between the countries is like
five less than five percent and it's
basically the energy that was vegas tan
is giving you know be killed and
obviously because this is seen as part
of the cooperation with the United
States yeah yeah the new so crude but
you know Silk Road on
Chiz I mean that's the watchword in
Washington everybody likes to talk about
it even though a lot of people already
believe that there is nothing new about
than you so growth right so I mean
there's a lot of contradiction and and
you know I I believe hamid karzai
president hamid karzai when he was in
Washington the last time he actually
talked about the lack of interest on
behalf of Uzbekistan in doing anything
with the Afghan government yeah yeah I
mean that was that issue was raised
David did you ever yeah no just on that
point I think this will obviously this
whole new silk route has has already
succeeded but I you know there was a
story just the other week about this one
thousands of tons of Afghan raisins
rotting in me Muslims pastor Ted am is
because and because presumably the
customs were not being paid to write
them out to get them across but it does
seem very unfortunate that that that
hasn't happened but it goes back to what
I'm saying really is that there is no
coverage of Afghanistan is this great
security risk but you get a you know a
long documentary about human rights
defender sitting the Harris who is this
great sort of enemy of the state and
that's the domestic consumption of
security that seems to be important for
the internal regime just want to make
quick comment about Russia up a
googly-eye most important a new brothers
operator bein Alex this what seems to be
a shift in Russian policy towards so
building this the subcircuit encircling
movement around as best analyst a new
economic and military engaging the case
down in Tajikistan and effectively
waiting it seems to me for Rebecca Stan
more or less to implode or to come back
to compare begging for assistance when
things start to go wrong the relation of
the United States I think that's
something that it certainly happened
before is this miscalculation on the
part of
and what they can expect for Washington
you know I remember back in two thousand
three people saying oh we want to be
that you know the Israel of the Central
Asia stranger anyway Georgians used to
say that too yeah well exactly yeah sort
of no questions asked relationship which
you give us lots of funding and we do
what you say but but in reality of
course it's not going to be like that
and I think that misunderstanding how
Washington works is still there and that
nuts calculation might come through
again which is another good reason why
it's worth pushing a bit harder in these
niggas right to say look we're being
last you for now but the reality is
especially when they see things like
picking cotton is hot shot at the
national service yes you know who's
makes take such huge fight you guys do
not understand how vitality you know I
mean look at her you know should grow up
picking cotton there is nothing wrong
way I look at him I mean we all did I
mean you know it's you have to have the
right answers when you are throwing such
comments right you have to be prepared
to respond and for that again you have
to have enough political will to be
pushing back oh great okay so let's
bundle the last three comments because I
want to get all of you in this under did
you want to that's good please so please
let's let's let's take Steve ed and
Sanjar and then we'll come back to the
panel for one last round of concluding
thoughts text thank you everyone very
very informative and certainly I don't
want to be seen as the naive optimist in
the room i'm not i think we I think we
sort of I do think we agree that it's it
does oil down a political will and I
think one of the lessons that I feel
I've learned is that sometimes really
small symbolic acts can can lead to
small improvements maybe even before
2014 David I was really interested in
this idea that also has been raised by
viola von krama in the bundestag that
Uzbekistan should not be seen as the
provider of regional security but as or
the victim of external threats but the
you know but generating and create
regional instability and my question to
all of you is politically in the EU and
NATO in Washington also possibly I just
wanted to throw as a wild card into the
mix in Ankara in Seoul two countries
that have really key relationships with
Rebecca sent how can we begin to maybe
promote that narrative that discourse
that is Becca Stan really is dangerous
in the region to Afghanistan to
Afghanistan how can that be done
politically because if that and I think
part of its probably in the media so
that would be a second question is how
do you generate that interest in in the
media but if that happens do you think
that might actually shift some momentum
and create some additional political
will to push harder in negotiations to
see whose Becca Stan in a different way
great thanks ed Schatz who will be
giving a talk tomorrow on his research
on views perceptions changing
perceptions of America and Central Asia
and he's a professor at the University
of Toronto and we're delighted could be
here a day or later join us Thanks huh
thanks Alex yeah just a quick question
it make sure follows pretty well and
Steve some commentary and question I'm
wondering about the about the narrative
that how the narrative of curry moves
response or non response to the ocean
vents plays out in Washington and
Brussels and whether or not that doesn't
give a certain a certain space and for
how long that on the ground what do you
what do you hear does this give him a
pass and how long will that passed last
and Sundra
yesterday s 01 interesting sentence New
York ski herbal sparkle and I want to
speak about Washington opcom the problem
I think is what you know united states
is super power is huge and the people in
Washington people who think about all
the world yeah and and for example in
the State Department the uzbek is done
it's not high level people who who
decide in decision-making on aspects
it's medium level people first of all
and also another things is what i saw in
2005 the people told me he knows angela
is in some country something happened
it's only six bounds on the rudder in
Washington because other after six
months in other players other things
will happen i don't know Heidi tube8
cetera so a project on start to all on
the radar this country everything forget
about who's Pakistan and after six
months they will think about speak about
other country so i want to say what it's
impossible to change during six months
in some country so in this case I think
it was much better poor uzbekistan for
example for the country like Las Vegas
down and for the United States also to
have state country partnership I mean
not all US will biggest and partnership
but for example one state mississippi
Tennessee River spec is now other state
with other country in that case because
it also the same dimension you know
uzbekistan ddb it's much even less than
tennessee budget you know so it's it's
comparable and there is a Senate there
is a legislative bodies in the center in
the states so it will for the state this
will be permanent partment partnership
what for six months now that's an
interesting idea right state Lallana my
god York oboes welcome and Washington
I've come my help to in-state love this
case alright folks you have one minute
each for any final thoughts and wrap up
well you raised a very good point about
osh of course he gained a lot of pop a
lot of points in Brussels was quite
clear both in NATO and EU I was
surprised myself one day to pray scary
muffin Russian TV about his reaction it
hasn't happened a lot in my life very
measured excellent speaking points from
the Minister of Foreign Affairs you
remember that during the OSHA vans
Kazakhstan was chairing the USC if you
compared the weight ashkan behaved the
way it spoke about his behaviors and
don't forget that they left immediately
to my greatest surprise both the UNHCR
and the ICRC to get access to the
refugees in the Fergana Valley and the
way they spoke on TV and radio their
international Statesman they were much
above what causes done said Kazakhstan
was in this case extremely mean and I
must say we were not accustomed to that
usually the minister of foreign affairs
of Kazakhstan knows how to speak to the
world and and indeed you're right he did
win a lot of points then what we all
know is that you had immediately DSN be
working to frighten the refugees there
and to make sure that after four days
that they would move back on Human
Rights Watch work sorry if I
if I gave the impression that I thought
your recommendations were naive no I
think they're very well phrased and you
you think them through very very well
and you Steve are doing a wonderful job
on Ernest Pakistan and we know how
frustrating it is but I was just
bringing my analysis as I think as I as
I corrected be a little bit if the
analysis of the first planner and the
economy turns right within in the coming
months then your recommendations will be
straight on target because the the
regime will need money and then the
leverage in the negotiations will change
side thanks yes a very good point on
lush I thought also as I Lance said
Kareem have got a good deal of credit
for that but he has finally run out
perhaps but it does raise the question
of a a post Kareem of regime we
shouldn't necessarily think is it's
going to be a particular friend of peace
and security in the region there's a
real potential for a much more
nationalist regime even if it may be
more liberal on some other issues
internally on this point about as well
as a source of insecurity yeah i think
is it is quite a hard message to get
across but i think even just trying to
deconstruct this trope that is appearing
on do you say you a defense minister
using it that you know because as best
on face of these problems we have to
leave them as much kid as possible on
our way out i think some way of
challenging that perhaps in the media
would be quite good maybe some kind of
reporting on actually the root of the
IMU for example or indeed on the role of
aspects done outsiders becca Stan
which it isn't something a few people
are working on I think that could be
very useful indeed and just finally on
that point i mean really i think one
issue that you know you mentioned as
well in a way is this issue of
information for example on the economy
we don't really have as far as i know
really good reporting mechanism that
will feed into international process so
for officials who come to his backs done
quite new and that happens all the time
right for people in Washington it's
great to have reports on your desk
that's a no this is what's really
happening the economy not what you're
being told by this Vic embassy or the
respect American Chamber of Commerce or
one of these interest groups so I think
we do need to try and think about ways
to generate more research and more
information I mean you know it's very
well known to everybody that was vegas
10 lives in an information vacuum the
majority of people not only don't know
what's happening inside the country but
outside the country to and to me unless
that information vacuum breaks it's
really hard to expect anything what you
hear a lot in Washington is you know
they like to say well changes should
really come from within the country and
I mean it's a nice thing to say but my
question to them usually is well what
are you doing or how are you how
interested are you to help those changes
you know to happen and I think that will
be the question of the day as we
continue I think county tourism and
counter-narcotics will be two major
projects that us will be working very
closely with us Pakistan no matter what
because those are good issues to explain
you know for us policymakers and
congress to they can get the funding for
that but i'm not sure that the interest
and focus and funding for other programs
that we'd like to see will happen i
completely agree with you on or I think
but just to add very quickly the
refugees that were coming from you know
from onshore major headache for
president karima he did not want them I
mean number one mayor religious and
these people are used to criticizing
their government I mean I mean he was
happily willing to send them home and
also I mean despite all the credit that
he got for the fact that he did not get
into any kind of an armed conflict with
kyrgyzstan he did wait for three days
before taking action and he did also you
know consult with the region with with
russia and kazakhstan on this so um dos
mi great thank you well first I I really
want to thank some people before we
break thank you so much to a central
Eurasia project for their partnership in
this and especially gala share for his
help in organizing this thanks to the
panelists who have come from very far
away to be here and we we certainly
appreciate it we hope you enjoy New York
City a little bit in between thinking
about these topics and it would be our
great pleasure to welcome you back and
we hope we can keep it keep in touch and
just a big thanks to the Harriman staff
they just put on over 100 events a year
they do it seamlessly they're fantastic
and it's just a real privilege to work
with them and even though most of left
it's on video tapes that they can
appropriately see it just to
announcement the first is a lot has been
said about money laundering taking your
money offshore where we'll actually
doing a money laundering conference here
in April on Central Asia and offshore
world so please come it's April second
same format half a day a mix of
different speakers actually our own
Scott warden will be on one of the
panels so again it'll be open to the
public we hope the scene thank you to
everyone this is really fantastic thanks
to the crowd and I hope we can do this
again someday thank you